[Music]
hello
hi welcome
i'm jonathan larson
i am 29 years old i work at the moon
dance diner
okay one sec do we take reservations no
we do not say we're we're a diner
i have an original rock musical hey boy
genius and i have spent the last eight
years of my life writing he's getting
out you're gonna be rich and famous
and rewriting you dragon yet oh i'm
getting so close
and rewriting can i hear it any day now
eight years
and the time keeps ticking
tick tick you need to ask are you
letting yourself be led by fear or by
love
fear a 100 fear
i don't know what the show is
why
do we play with fire
what if the workshop happens and nothing
changes what then jonathan
maybe i'm just wasting my time
do you know how many jonathan larsons
there are
one why should we place a trail
there's not enough time
i went to three friends funerals last
year
and nobody is doing enough
i'm not doing enough
try writing about what you know
what does it take
to wake up the generation
it would be a tragedy to give up what
you
have baby don't say the answers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you